so i've asked a few friends what they
thought about resident evil's new
netflix show
infinite darkness it stinks
but i thought i'd take a look for myself
since i'm a huge re fan and i also did a
ton of research for this video let's see
here resident evil 8 ultra bikini
jiggle physics costume
[Music]
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into resident evil infinite
darkness and asking the big question
why was this 4 25 minute episodes and
not just one
two hour movie actually we'll be talking
a lot about the ending and how this
story connects to the greater resident
evil universe
so grab your green herbs and dwindling
supply of ammo and make sure to like and
subscribe
seriously only three percent of you are
subscribed because here we
go resident evil the events of infinite
darkness would never have occurred if it
weren't for the civil war in panama stan
way back in the year 2000 roughly two
years after the events of code veronica
the u.s military sent
troops into the small fictitious country
under the pretense of spreading peace
and democracy
of course nearby china doesn't take too
kindly to this they don't exactly like
having a strong u.s military presence on
their border
that's why six years later when zombies
invade the white house and one of
america's subs is mysteriously destroyed
u.s secretary of defense wilson is quick
to blame the chinese that's because
wilson secretly wants a war between
china
and the us as we learn throughout the
series four episodes wilson has been
secretly working with a mysterious
pharmaceutical company
developing bioweapons this company turns
out to be tricel which you may remember
as being the company responsible for the
plaga outbreak in kujuju
the location where much of resident evil
5 is based
wilson's plan is pretty insane he
purposely infects a group of u.s
soldiers called the mad dogs and then
blackmails them into doing his bidding
by withholding the cure from them
you see wilson controls these things
called inhibitors which
inhibit the growth of the virus within
their bodies and since he's the only one
who has access to these inhibitors these
soldiers have to do what he says or
they risk turning into mutated zombies
so wilson uses the mad dogs as his
personal covert ops group allowing him
to gain clout within the white house
eventually working his way up to
secretary of defense
just like resident evil 2 infinite
darkness has two storylines one of leon
kennedy
and claire redfield leon has been called
by the president to look into a recent
hack of one of the government's top
secret servers and the president
trusts leon after all it was leon who
saved his daughter which play out in
resident evil 4.
i knew you'd be fine if you landed on
your butt those events occur roughly two
years before that of infinite darkness
player on the other hand works for a
company called terrasave i kid you not
their motto is because
tare doesn't have to end with orist
they're an ngo looking to help build
schools and hospitals in war-torn
regions like panamastan
the last we saw of claire
chronologically was in resident evil
degeneration which is set a year before
the events of
infinite darkness claire wants to get to
the bottom of the mysterious outbreak
that happened in penangstan in 2000
an outbreak she believed was covered up
just like the one she experienced in
raccoon city in 1998.
this gets her tased and tied to a chair
where the big baddie wilson discusses
his entire plan
it's kind of sad to see claire redfield
relegated to damsel in distress when my
experience with her in the games is that
she's a total badass
we never get to see that in infinite
darkness meanwhile leon teams up with
shenmei
and jason who will later find out want
to expose wilson's plan
shenmei's brother was infected with the
virus while working as a soldier in
panama stand
he's currently being held in some sort
of coma state by shenme's wealthy
grandfather jason on the other hand was
a former mad dog's member who can't stop
talking about fear and terror
do you know where the root of terror
comes from terrifying
fear fear fear terror theater fear
fear terror fear terror fear
it's shenme's brother who holds the key
to exposing wilson's plan
every infected mad dog member was
embedded with a chip that recorded their
vitals in combat data
this ties wilson to the infected and is
the proof they need to stop him once and
for all
but jason has tracked down wilson to his
underground lap
and mutates into this creature before
biting wilson
wilson will survive the encounter only
later to be given an inhibitor by that
mysterious company
trisal we know that tricel has links to
albert wesker so it's possible he may be
secretly pulling the strings
jason seems to be a lost cause he thinks
that by showing
everyone what fear is he'll stop
tragedies like the one he
experienced from ever happening
for true again it's the only way
to keep this tragedy from ever happening
again he believes by
exposing wilson it'll shock the world so
that the tragedy that befell him and his
team
as well as penam stan and raccoon city
will never happen again
because it's only through fear that
people will be terrified into action
leon disagrees with this at the end of
the episode in one of the
very few scenes with both claire and
leon claire asks leon to hand
over the chip she wants to send it to
all the newspapers to expose this huge
bioweapon conspiracy
but in an interesting twist leon says no
thanks
bro and this could serve two purposes
one so that leon can handle this on his
own
setting up more seasons of the show and
two to go against what
jason said in the final episode jason
tells leon that
even though jason will die it's too late
leon will help the fear spread
if the news of this bioweapon conspiracy
gets out it's gonna cause a tremendous
amount of fear with world war
implications imagine if china found out
the us was experimenting with bio-weapon
super soldiers right next to its border
on the other hand if leon keeps the chip
and takes matters into his own hands he
can potentially stop that
in essence leon wants to have his cake
and eat it too
he wants to stop tricel and wilson while
making sure the world doesn't panic
and now for a quick 30 second review did
i like resident evil infinite darkness
i don't ever remember being a part of
your crappy script not really i felt
claire was totally underused the
storyline was predictable and the
villains were over the top cheesy but
you know that's kind of the way with
resident evil at least in the games you
have the awesome
gameplay to supplement the story and i
gotta be honest there were times i was
watching this and grabbed my playstation
controller because i thought a boss
fight was gonna happen
the new resident evil live-action show
was just announced i just hope they can
fix some of this writing because this
franchise is so
near and dear to my heart but what did
you think of resident evil infinite
darkness i want to hear your thoughts in
the comments below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much